May 2009 the European Space Agency
launches the Planck satellite to search
for the birth of dark energy it's ultra
sensitive telescope peers through space
and time back through billions of years
towards the beginning of everything to
capture this this is our universe as it
appeared over 13 billion years ago
380,000 years after the Big Bang
so what Planck has done is take a
picture of the early universe and told
us about what the early universe is like
and given us our most detailed and
accurate picture of that moment in time
the universe in this picture is a hot
soup of protons electrons and photons
hydrogen atoms have just started to form
and it's the light from this genesis of
matter that we see here
blue areas are colder Reds are warm
eventually those hotspots those red
spots you see in the map are going to
form large super clusters made up of
hundreds or thousands of galaxies each
wow those galaxies will contain billions
of stars gravity and expansion alone
appear to drive the formation of these
embryonic galaxies dark energy doesn't
seem to have switched on yet so when did
dark energy take control of the universe